welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy with a big
Huang like
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy with a big
huyang and this video we're breaking
down a soccer episode 4.
[Music]
midpoint of the series and the episodes
packed with Easter eggs hidden details
and a lot of things going on with it
that we need to talk about picking up
immediately after last week's entry that
saw a sucker and Co discovering the eye
of Scion appet racing the Superstar
Destroyer tracking device this of course
also explains how Hera shows up this
week going against some of the Council
of senator's orders now there have been
theories that some of them are still in
line with the Empire which remains to be
seen But as we know there are Imperials
in every aspect of the new Republic
anyway Asoka and Co ended up Landing in
the forest which is when droids were
sent out after them and that takes us
into the brand new entry directed by
Peter Ramsey he co-directed into the
spider-verse and season 3 episode 5 of
the Mandalorian now we begin with the T6
crew trying to fix the ship so they can
reach out to home one with what's going
on building a gigantic hyperdrive would
would be pretty big news and it would
likely confirm that they're indeed
trying to get thrown this would raise a
lot of issues with the new Republic and
it would usher in in the air to the
Empire which is a story that he actually
came to prominence in
allowing thrawn's return as heir to the
Empire
now we know that thrawn welcome back to
this galaxy due to comments made by the
shadow Council in the Mandalorian
however we also know that he'll be
defeated before somehow Palpatine
returned and that he will be the main
threat instead that the Rebellion has to
fight I was actually thinking about this
the other day and I started to wonder
whether Star Wars would be better if
everything was told chronologically
instead we have we have stuff like Rogue
one which tells the plans of the Death
Star being stolen and then and or
released a couple years after which is
set during the creation of it you then
got this followed by the Mandalorian
season 3 set after Return of the Jedi
and then Ahsoka kinda set during season
two of The Mandalorian which is
happening before the sequel movies that
released before all this took place but
we're watching it after just something
to think about and I do feel it's
difficult to maintain the full tension
when you know ahsoka's coming back in
the book of Bob Affair and thrawn gets
beaten and the reason why thrawn is so
sought after is because of how much of a
master strategist that he is and he
never actually lost straight up or in a
one-to-one battle outside of the one on
lothal Drawn even studied hara's artwork
to decimate her entire fleet and he's a
Next Level genius when it comes to
combat to Morgan he's the only one who
can bring the Empire back to full power
which will no doubt lead into the end of
the Empire film series at Dave filoni's
planning the word Scion even means air
and they're slowly putting these things
in place to build up towards it now I
love the Mystique and mystery around
this and you really get the idea of cost
with it as well they're gonna have to
sacrifice saving Ezra from who knows
where and leaving him stranded out there
in space this is because bringing back
thrawn is gonna be worse than what they
get from saving him and yeah I love the
whole idea of course that comes with it
the score is incredible throughout the
episode too and they really knock it out
of the park with the entire atmosphere
Sabine also calls Ahsoka fulcrum and in
case you don't know this was a code name
in Rebels now she says if we can't make
the jump to Ezra then no one should
that's because Ahsoka is trying to
prepare Sabine to destroy the star map
which she believes is what needs to
happen now we see a Droid looking on and
yeah I was kind of like why don't they
just send in loads of those droids to
self-destruct it and blow themselves up
before they have a chance to react also
why do they have a countdown on them if
they're just gonna solved it look never
mind yeah they very much get the idea
that things are ramping up though and we
then go to the bad guys located at The
Shrine you might notice that Shin Smiles
are bailin's faith in her ability and
she does sort of give Morgan a dirty
look she does not like Morgan at all and
I feel like Morgan is Shin's ryanairie
shut the up Ryan Airy I forgot to
mention this in the case of Morgan but
the actress who plays there's actually
Bruce Lee's goddaughter her name's Diana
Lee and osanto and the reason I bring it
up is because I actually think we missed
a Bruce Lee Easter egg back in episode
one when she was rescued on the
prisonership we could see her in a
yellow jumpsuit sitting in a Cell this
might have actually been a reference to
he says yellow suit and Game of Death
but to be fair it might also be a Rouge
now Morgan senses the fear and balance
voice and he's likely worried due to
what he heard from Anakin this gets
touched upon later on and we of course
get that beginning scene that will we'll
talk about towards the end of the video
it's also down to the fact that if they
ever Point themselves in the wrong
direction so much is a millimeter then
that's gonna equal millions and billions
of miles away from their target when
they come out the other side of the
hyperdrive the episode itself is called
Fallen Jedi and this actually refers to
a number of people Percy there's bailin
who's now more in line with his safe and
a saga Who falls before going to the
world Between Worlds lastly we of course
have the most famous Fallen Jedi of them
all who comes face to face with his
Apprentice at the end of the entry now
back at the T6 we can see the cups still
on the table from last week she's moved
it but it's probably been by hand and
Sabine starts to man up and prepare all
her weapons Ahsoka sea sabine's fear of
losing Ezra so she starts to ask if
she's worried about the situation she's
trying to get Sabine to Reign her fear
in and this is so she doesn't risk the
mission and not destroy the star map she
needs her to do it she needs to do
what's necessary but in the end we see
that she doesn't this idea of fear is of
course reflected and bailing and I feel
like it's a major theme running
throughout the century everything is
revolving around what could be on either
side of that hyperspace Lane but now
they've also embraced the timey why me
wibbly wobbly stuff that comes with the
world Between Worlds and this was first
introduced in Rebels and it allowed Ezra
to save Ahsoka from a battle with Bader
in the past this is somewhere she
seemingly perished whereas Anakin's
arrival is is more like a force ghost
thing the world Between Worlds Bridges
belt time and space and it may be the
power that balen was referring to and
the way that hyperspace works is that
it's like an extra Dimension beneath the
surface of space that you can access
once you travel past a certain speed
this takes you into becoming almost like
a wave of light yourself so you pass
through objects rather than smashing
them like the like button now before nav
computers developed the first Travelers
used to follow the Paragould migration
path through this and it would stop them
from dropping out of it at a point where
they'd hit into a star or a planet they
mapped these out as safe hyperspace
lanes and would then use them as a way
to travel a force users also became
adapted it because they could sense when
it was safe to drop out of a Lanes
stopping them from crashing into
something another reason the pergola
maps are needed to get to thrawn is
because most people who travel into
these other galaxies haven't come back
because of the type of engines you'd
need to do it with and the fuel that it
would require thus they're having to go
back to the old ways in order to do this
which is why it's not necessarily just a
case of traveling at light speed to get
to the next galaxy anyway back at the
ship we see huyang has been programmed
with really impressive self-defense
systems he's actually someone I kinda
hope to see bust out those forearms in
and do a General Grievous packing
lightsabers and just cutting people down
they've not really touched upon it in
the show but he's actually thousands of
years old and has been in number of
combat situations who Yang is someone
who crafted lightsabers for the Jedi
over Millennia and I think that having
him get some of these out and just going
mental with them would be such a cool
thing to have up here in the show at
this point more droids come in and who
Yang rips the power to alert his mates
he's in danger I'm pretty sure this is
the first time in the series at sabine's
rocked her for Hellman armor which was
something that she of course fought with
a lot in Rebels this is of course made a
best score which allows her to block
Blaster bolts like we see happening in
this scene butchi and Osaka make quick
work of the grunts with Ahsoka even
using the force to hold one up as a
human shield Sabine also uses a wrist
wire to pull one in which allows Ahsoka
to get the killing blow this wrist wire
is something Boba Fett used on Luke and
Return of the Jedi and if you ever
played the Bounty Hunter game you know
you busted it out all the time either
way it's really nice seeing them kind of
working together and it shows at least
to this points the beans holding back
when it comes to using her lightsaber
she's still coming off the back of the
Larson episode 1 so it makes sense why
she's sticking to a comfort zone by just
using the blasters he's at a soccer
answer being complement each other
really well and gives the advice that
they shouldn't split up biang is proven
right when sabeed and Ahsoka gets
separated by the end of the episode and
yeah stay together
you always did better that way now this
isn't a sponsored ad or anything yet but
I just want to give a shout out to our
mate Josh over at denim nerds who's just
launched a Kickstarter for his graphic
novel Unity Josh has crafted an
incredible Judge Dread meets watchman's
story to bring you This brilliant book
drawn by Daredevil artist Neto Diaz said
in the far future we find humanity at
the brink of collapse due to a war with
superheroes that almost destroyed the
species United by an artificial being
known as modest who watches this
attempts to bring us back from the brink
of Extinction I've chipped into it on
the kickstarter and I hope you guys do
too as it does need funding to bring it
to life the links in the description if
you want to check it out and see some of
the rewards that you can get from
pledging to the kickstarter now
elsewhere we cut back to home one and
catch Jason Hera and that homicidal
maniac Chopper that was really funny how
Jason asks her out why he always has to
follow orders but she doesn't was
chatting to empty about this and he said
he said if that boy isn't careful yet
his rebellious nature could lead him to
the dark side he's gonna need a good
teacher now I kind of feel like Sabine
may be the one who teaches him and even
though she's not fully Force sensitive
she does know the training and and what
you should be doing now she's also
joined by Carson Teva who we last Saw
hanging out with seven Rebels I'm kind
of hoping that they also bring him back
to how we can have a reunion with the
old ghost crew back with Morgan we watch
his user's night sister magic to light
up the Austria man this can be seen in
the green glow beneath it this creates
markings and waypoints just like the
temple seemingly directing it to where
thrawn is now Mt has done an incredible
breakdown of these circles and what they
represent in terms of the greater Star
Wars lore exploring zepho and Fallen
order he found several things that
linked this with the will Between Worlds
and overall a lore of the Star Wars
Universe the first similarities are the
circles which are abundant throughout
the environment with three figures also
being married too in the sapphire tombs
you had to push astriums around to solve
puzzles and and the three figures we've
seen throughout the tombs are holding
three astriums as well the hands are in
similar poses and they also have ties
with the triquetra II the triquetra
represents a trinity and we've seen
three night sister figures throughout
all of the tombs we also have the
triquetra potentially linked to Balin
shin and Marek with their opposites
being Ahsoka Sabine and Hera lots of
these opposite sides going on and the
force in general is of course about
balance anyway I don't want to go too in
depth on it because there's a lot to
discuss but if this is peaked your
interest then definitely check out
empty's video from last week breaking it
all down turn the channel now and also
just in general huge thank you for all
your support when it comes to Mt I feel
like you guys have really welcomed him
at the channel and you know it's nice
reading those comments and thinking
maybe one day I'll be able to retire and
leave this all YouTube business alone
anyway we cut to Sabine in a circle in
the forest before they run into shin and
Marik in general forests are an
important location in Star Wars as they
thematically allow one to be closer to
the force is definitely the idea of
anti-industrialization through Star Wars
and the Imperials of course embody this
and their lifeless gray Machinery Darth
Vader was of course more man the machine
and the Death Star itself was like an
artificial moon on the other side of
this Luke went to dagobada started
training with Yoda and one of Return of
the Jedi's major battles took place on
Endor this showed how the small natural
living Ewoks could overcome the might of
the Empire which is something I always
feel when they have Forest themes like
this Rosario Dawson actually said at d23
that these were her favorite scenes in
the entire series with the red leaves
giving off an almost burnt out look he
said that they got lost in the set and
felt like it came to life with creatures
moving in it and mushrooms growing on
trees it apparently started fermenting
as well and parts of Shin's wig started
turning purple because of the
environment I think it really pops off
screen and it's nice going from the
industrial places in episode 2 to space
in three and then natural environments
like this before either way it leads to
a big deal with Ahsoka taking on Marek
and Sabine and shin going toe-to-toe
Sabine strikes first which very much
shows her status as a Padawan as Jedi
are usually slow to draw their weapons
and only do side of defense for Sabine
to be the first to draw her weapon shows
a great degree of fear and anger at the
person who of course stabbed her and
wants to take Ezra away from her now
Asoka manages to kill Marek but he
doesn't make a sound and when he goes
down we see some green gas escaping his
suit I think right I think Marek I think
Marek might might actually be weed I am
weed now I was leaked a couple of days
ago that Mark was gonna be smoke and
when I first got told it I genuinely
thought they said snoke but nope guy is
actual smoke inhabiting an Inquisitor
suit
foreign
[Music]
and all the theories all the connections
to Ezra Galen Marek all of them it went
up in smoke and I'm done I'm done Disney
you I'm done and I'll see
you in hell yeah nah so obviously you
know us boys gotta become men and take
our eyes when it comes to it and I want
to hold my hands up and say that I was
wrong shout out to everyone everyone who
guessed he was actually just a pile of
smoke all of you who got it right yeah
cute you give yourself a pat on the back
if you guessed that one and I I know if
you're writing it in the comments yeah I
believe you you knew it all along anyway
let's put our personal feelings of
embarrassment and humiliation to the
side and go over exactly what this is
now Marek being Smoke from Mortal Kombat
explains why they had to use older
Inquisitor armor for him and we could
see scratches and dents in it when we
got a close-up look of him or it and
this also explains why Marek wasn't with
Shina balen at the start and it was only
after they freed Morgan that he started
to appear in the show this is something
we've actually seen before and in Tales
of the Jedi we did see something similar
during the final Ahsoka episode of the
series we watched she went toe-to-toe
with an Inquisitor and upon killing him
the mask landed on the floor and
deflated like this reveal smoke came out
of it and this is a similar situation
towards going on with Mark here the
green smoke coming out shows that this
is night sister magic meaning that it
was Morgan who summoned him and yeah
that's just one of the big Clues you
know a similar thing happened to Savage
oppress when he was struck down by Darth
Sidious and it is something that we've
seen throughout the Saga before
obviously people are gonna have their
own opinions on it I'm sure they'll all
be civil and but yeah let me know your
thoughts below and exactly what you what
you felt seeing this reveal and
generally in this moment how you think
it was delivered now Ahsoka runs after
bailing while Sabine takes on Shin by
herself who Yang told them not to split
and in all honesty I feel like both
together would have smashed her like the
like button oh brother this guy stinks
Soca does have more pressing matters I
suppose as we get a ticking clock on the
map and bailing is there just ready to
go in this fight you might notice Ahsoka
draws her weapon first and this is
because Baylen doesn't really want to
fight her at all she does the old
ex-girlfriend put down and says Anakin
never mentioned him at all and he turns
Ahsoka trying to get her angry making
her tap into the dark side would be a
big loss for her but I actually feel
he's the one who's gonna turn feels like
he has a double side to him and
potentially he may be trying to get
thrown back unite the Empire and put
them all in one play so that they can be
destroyed let's be honest he's a Jedi he
might be wanting to bring them back and
getting all the all the bad guys wiped
out would be the best way to do it
uniting them would mean the Imperials
within all aspects of the new Republic
are finally ousted but yeah let me know
below exactly what you guys think now
soccer and Balin seem to adjust their
fighting stances based on what they see
the other doing which is a subtle way to
point out all their Jedi training huge
it out to Tom on the mic Big Buddy of
the channel and he noticed that Ahsoka
uses the same fighting stance that
Anakin used against Dooku in Attack of
the Clones attach the picture so you can
check it out and Yeah again shout out to
top of the mic really nice guy who Yang
toots have been some of those techniques
at the start of the last episode and
it's why the Jedi have to practice
sparring so much the lightsaber fight is
great I think this episode's easily the
best in the series so far there's great
build up with Dread throughout a payoff
year and we of course get the ending
that teases what what's coming next week
it just left me wanting more and after a
series that's left me feeling pretty
disappointed I was finally feeling like
yeah this this is Star Wars anyway we
cut to Sabine failing to use the force
and I love how Shin kind of flinches
even though it's nothing now Sabine
being able to train to use the force
without having any natural ability is
somehow it's caused a lot of contention
in the fan base but it has to be said
this was actually part of George Lucas
his original plan everyone has the force
in them everyone
there's two sides of the horse the dark
side which is selfishness
and the light side which is compassion
so we all struggle to keep these two
things in balance and hopefully we're
able to move it a little bit more toward
the bright side Lucas also said in
interviews that everyone can tap into it
and wield it to a certain level but this
must come with training and persistency
now there's also this idea of natural
talent in the force which is typically
given by those with high midichlorian
counts people like Anakin had abnormally
large ones and Percy had natural talent
and ability when wielding it the Jedi
understood this and when Force
sensitivity was identified at a young
age they take the kids possessing this
ability and train them repeatedly to
strengthen their bond we've also had
blind characters in stuff like Rogue one
who aren't Jedi but they tap into the
force to to help them with things I
don't think that Sabine will be coming
out on our Jedi but eventually she may
reunite with bulkitan and she could even
get the darksaber back if things go tits
up with bow again there's been theories
for years now that Han Solo unwittingly
used the force during several flight
missions and they seem to be leaning
more into that way of understanding
obviously some people are going to be
annoyed but I I kind of actually prefer
the idea that everyone can tap into it
with training and focus rather than just
being for select people who just so
happen to be born that way Yoda of
course said that the forces and
everything it binds and controls us did
you say something along those lines but
uh yeah obviously let me know your
thoughts below if you if you disagree
now she still has her wrist Rockets
though and she may end up going more in
line with that rather than trying to
become a Jedi we see is the fight with
Balin escalates and a saga grabs the
star map which is likely what ends up
sending her to the world Between Worlds
this Burns her but this being a mark
could be what actually allows her to
travel into the dimension a shin arrives
and this makes a circle believe that
Sabine is now dead she appears to use
the force on Shin out of anger and rage
which is uncharacteristic of this calm
and collected adult version of Ahsoka
her own attachment is a bean caused a
Soca briefly to act out of rage and this
may even be the reason why she stopped
training her however Sabine is okay but
she hasn't got the guts to let Ezra go
and instead she hands over the star map
bailing connects to Sabine briefly
through the use of the force and he
senses her intentions before putting his
lightsaber away he seems to feel that
Sabine doesn't have it in her to destroy
her connection to Ezra which is why he
knows he can use his tongue to get her
to join him Balin does not like using
his lightsaber unless absolutely
necessary it seems and in the end he
just says do it this is of course
echoing Palpatine doing it to Anakin and
Revenge of the Sith and he tempts her
with the hope that she can get Ezra back
I actually think that he might even be
dead but we will find out because it
looks like they're going there very very
soon now she's choked out by Shin but I
think balen Caesar is an ally now and he
commands his Apprentice to just let it
go destroying the star map we see is the
new republic ships come in and almost
get destroyed by the Scion warp jump
this is of course very similar to hold
our remover which we've already shown
and I don't I don't I don't really want
to show more of that movie I also think
this is the first time we see the S
files going into attack position from a
cockpit and you get a couple of shots
like with a rhodian pilot where you can
see them opening up we also get a closer
look at the eye of Scion and can see
both it and the window are modeled after
an eyeball Jason says that he has a bad
feeling about this which is of course a
reference to the famous line that
appears in every movie in the original
trilogy it also shows that Jason has a
strong connection in the force even
without any training and yeah the guy's
starting to go more in line with his dad
either way everyone's gonna accept
huyang and ahsoka's now stuck in the
world Between Worlds here she comes
across the shot that's gonna break the
internet which is Anakin Skywalker back
in all his glory this is actually a redo
of a moment from Revenge of the Sith
with it being archival footage instead
of War I think is a new scene I feel
like they've just sort of taken that
moment deep play liked it and then added
it onto a CGI body and then had it move
around I'm sure we'll get some behind
the scenes stuff that explains exactly
what's going with it but just looking at
the similarities here between these two
shots that's that's what our Fields
happened now he's wearing the outfit
that he wears in the Clone Wars and he
also calls her Snips like Anakin used to
Ahsoka actually hated being called this
but you know when if someone was like
heavy spoilers there's more like heavy
himself I'd be like are you some of
a but if they died and then I
wasn't I was walking down an alley in a
hood heavy spoilers more like heavy
yourself a bit I I had to get a feeling
of joy you know what I mean I'd have a
feeling inside like he's back he's back
my friend who I hate they're back and
most of Anakin's face is covered in
Shadow and this possibly points out to
Anakin being more of a dark side
manifestation than what being part of
the light we can also hear Notes From
The Imperial March and this was of
course Vader's theme I do feel like he
he is gonna be a good guy but that there
is always that dark side that comes with
Anakin now Sabine and them they're on
the other side of space right now in a
galaxy far far away however using the
world Between Worlds a soccer can get to
them this can Bridge both time and space
and if Anakin can help her master it
then it's gonna allow her to jump to not
only where thrawn is but where Ezra is
too we might even get a Time jump to the
book of Boba Fett where potentially a
soccer goes back to the main Galaxy Anya
doesn't actually cease Sabine for a long
time either way I feel Hayden's gonna be
back in a lot of the series from this
point out and Rosario actually posted
that he was back last year but she was
told to hurry just delete it as quick as
you can however the internet's forever
um so yeah that picture is still out
there but yeah just seeing him back like
this it was really good um it is rumored
that he's gonna be in at least three
episodes and yeah getting this moment uh
I feel I just knocked it out the park
now as for hair in them I think mon
mothma will be the one to send out ships
to the Rendezvous and this actually has
a lot of tie backs to Rebels the first
time Hara and Monmouth met in the show
was due to the former saving the latter
leading to her going to lead the
rebellion and the new Republic she
likely sees the new republics falling
apart due to the bureaucracy and this is
something that lay even ended up having
to leave during the sequels the reason
she has her own set of rebels is because
she rebelled against the rebels and went
off to do her own thing I also think the
Senate appearing in Holograms was
supposed to resemble a shadow Council in
the Mandalorian potentially echoing how
their two wings of the same bird anyway
that wraps up the breakdown I'm sure you
can tell I really enjoy this episode you
know I did have problems with those
first three especially the first two I
just felt they were very boring didn't
really connect to the characters and
didn't really feel like they were giving
any emotions at all that's totally been
reversed here I think that the action
was paced really well I think there was
moments attention and when it came to
the emotion you know you could feel it
coming from the characters when people
like Ahsoka lose their cool it really
shows her inner thoughts and you know
just just all the parallel they were put
in I really enjoyed it ending on that
Cliffhanger as well was a great way to
go out and Yeah though I think that you
know the series hasn't exactly hit a
home run every week when I look at just
this episode I feel I knocked it out the
park that's a baseball metaphor and yeah
we're really happy with it over here at
the heavy spoilers Channel but um I know
some of you guys are still having a
tough time getting involved with the
show so if you are then let me know
below just been speaking with Greg from
real rejects about it as well he he
feels a bit more on the emotionally
detached side and didn't really like
this episode that much I don't think um
so yeah if you're one of them totally
fine you know I'm friends with people
who think that way and uh yeah if if you
disagree then let me know your comments
below and we there would love to read
them now if you drop a like on the video
we'd also massively appreciate that too
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button to get
early access to videos every week and I
go goes such a long way to helping us
out if you want to get some heavy
spoilers merch we've also got a t-shirt
line located just below the video that
will let you pick up in a soccer
inspired t-shirt we drop new designs on
there all the time so definitely keep an
eye out for them and it definitely helps
the channel and for us to just keep
going now if you want something else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now where either mt's talking about the
zephoto tombs or or something else I was
gonna advertise as Mark Theory videos
but uh after seeing this week will not
push that now uh yeah thanks again for
sitting through the video I've been Paul
and you know what I hope you enjoy the
rest of your day and thanks for saying
Until the End you've been the best peace